>>Cheryl: Research shows that if
the student's in the right mindset
and they get their sensory needs met,
they're going to be much
better learners.
>>Heather: Hands to your heart space.
Take a deep breath in.
[ inhale, exhale ]
>>Cheryl: The sensory room is probably
my most important piece of the day.
Students go to the sensory room
in order to calm their bodies
and get all the emotions out and
stabilize themselves, so they're ready
to learn and they're happy.
>>Heather: When we designed
the sensory room,
we actually took the entire room apart.
We carpeted the floor so that we
could absorb some of the sound.
We put the shades on the ceiling to
change the light, so when they walk
in that room, they feel the change.
>>Cheryl: My class specifically,
we utilize the room once a
day for a thirty minute break.
>>Heather: First thing that
they do is go on the ball
and they bounce to a metronome.
>>Clap.
>>It's really a way to
ground them into the space
and give them some sensory input, before
we have them go out into the room.
>>Cheryl: We're going to
do our rotation now, okay?
>>So there's different
stations in the sensory room,
and some of my students
love specific stations.
One in particular loves the
punching bags and the ropes.
He's able to get all that anger and
frustration out, so that calms him down.
Whereas another student, I know
he needs calming movements,
so he's on the swing
going back and forth.
>>Heather: Another area in
the room is the crash pad.
You will see students that have sensory
issues bump into walls, bang their head.
So what we've created is a
safe space to crash into.
And then there's the light wall.
You could use your hands,
you could use your feet.
There's different games that
are programmed on there.
>>Teacher: Yes, good girl.
>>Heather: We also work on
balance and coordination.
The walking path works on all of those,
and they have to right themselves,
correct their body in space.
We have ten pound slam balls.
Some students just need to come in,
pick something heavy up and throw it.
That's the essence of a sensory room.
You're putting materials in
there that are appropriate,
so a student's not throwing a chair.
And at the end when they
finish with their stations,
they lay on the floor
and they're squished.
So everything that we do in there is
predictable, there's a set sequence.
>>Cheryl: We're all done
with sensory room.
We're going to walk back to our class.
>>So after the sensory room,
they're able to focus more.
They're quieter and their hands
are to themselves, and they're able
to listen to my directions.
We're here, we came from the
sensory room, we're ready to learn.
>>How does the sensory
room make you feel?
>>Student: Happy.